in Bimini Bahamas a team of experts are
hoping to entice a couple sharks for an
experiment
and get more than they bargained for
they're testing if sharks can detect
magnetic fields the answer could unlock
a major mystery about how sharks find
far-flung food rich volcanic islands and
whether the islands naturally magnetic
lava rock is involved for this open
water experiment they arranged three
powerful magnets to the right and three
non-magnetic controls to the left a big
hammerhead glides over the aluminum
control without a glance and heads for
the magnets
hammerheads ignore the aluminum
clustering around the magnets
the nurse sharks have a greater response
[Music]
nurse sharks are drawn to the magnets
the Sharks are agitated possibly by the
magnets
[Music]
that was fantastic
that was great so many hammerheads down
there all over the place
bunch of nurse sharks and their sharks
were fighting at the magnets really neat
dive all around yeah so that dive was
crazy we had nine hammerheads there
seemed like countless nurse sharks what
we saw was that both the nurse sharks
and the hammerheads did respond to the
magnets so what we can take away from
that is that those weak magnetic fields
that are locked in volcanic rock are
something that the Sharks could detect
and may be able to use in navigation
[Music]
you